les hommes et les femmes qui ont marqué
l'année 83 l'entretien d'aujourd'hui est
consacrée à bernard tapie
hervé chabalier reçoit l'industriel le
plus prolifique pourrait-on dire de
france
il rachète tout ce qui est à vendre
parfois même les aubes bernard hinault
par exemple qui courra l'année prochaine
sous ses couleurs
38 ans et toutes ses dents des dents de
requin des dents de loup et un sourire
de séducteur bernard tapie est un
marginal il réussit là où les autres
patrons échoue il se moque des
institutions c'est un gagneur il reprend
des affaires maladie les soigne avec ses
copains ses collaborateurs il trouve les
vitamines indispensables au sauvetage
des entreprises agonisante
ça marche ça tourne son groupe couvrent
des secteurs aussi divers que les arts
graphiques l'agroalimentaire la
cosmétologie le pesage le matériel
audiovisuel et le prêt-à-porter chiffre
d'affaires 3 milliards et demi de francs
ces succès ont presque fini par faire
oublier quelques aventures douteuses
comme le rachat du château de bokassa il
a même fini par s'acheter un homme pas
n'importe lequel
bernard hinault alors bernard hinault va
courir le tour de france mais vous vous
courez après quoi si on avait un peu de
temps je reprendrai votre chapeau dans
l'ordre parce que là dedans il est plein
de choses dans laquelle je suis je me
donne suffit pas d'abord sur le mont
marginal car en fait je suis le
contraire d'un marginal ce fait un
métier qui est très classique qui
consiste à effectivement avoir une bonne
connaissance technologique d'abord de ce
que c'est l'industrie et par rapport à
la vision mondiale d'un homme d'affaires
je crois que suis pas marginal ce qui
est marginal c'est l'homme d'affaires
français qui lui par rapport à la
collectivité de l'homme d'affaires
devient marginale enfin c'est quand je
parlais des institutions oui j'adore les
jurys mais pas les institutions et bien
sûr j'aime pas le cnpf prêt marginal et
c'est vos pneus je trouve qui sert pas à
grand chose mais enfin bernard hinault
je me suis pas offert on n'achète pas un
homme de cette qualité là on se met à
travailler avec lui parce que j'avais
des choses à lui de mai il avait des
choses à m'apporter alors peut-être vous
pourrez répondre à la question vous
courez après quoi en fait quand on a la
chance de savoir faire quelque chose qui
à la fois vous fait plaisir et vous
nourrit bien en général on n'arrête pas
de le faire et ma course en avant est
pratiquement le le résultat d'une
affaire qui se met sur une autre qui se
cumulent les unes après les autres qui
vous amènent à ne plus savoir
après quoi vous courez en fait je crois
que c'est un as mais pourriez pas arrêté
financièrement pour arrêter
intellectuellement je crois pas parce
que j'ai pris cette habitude avec ce
rythme de travail et si je l'avais plus
je prends le seul manquerait
alors on dit souvent que vous êtes le
samu hier par une entreprise va pas vous
arrivez vous la remettez vous l'a
racheté peu puis vous restez de la
remettre en route
l'économie française est elle est un peu
malade aussi alors si vous étiez
ministre l'économie
quels sont les trois premières mesures
que vous prendriez la première je crois
que l'essentiel de l'économie repose sur
des éléments subjectifs et une grande
part repose sur des éléments irrationnel
vous savez les grands professeurs
d'économie sont bien incapables
aujourd'hui de m'expliquer pourquoi le
dollar a pris soin autant de valeur par
rapport au franc en l'espace de deux ans
et demi sur des éléments objectifs et
rationnels dont je crois que la première
des choses et c'est à des éléments
d'ailleurs qui nouveau du succès dans
notre prise d'affaires en difficulté
c'est de réinstaller la confiance en soi
l' envie de réussir l'enthousiasmé tu
sais et je crois que la monnaie est le
reflet incontestablement de l'opinion
générale que le monde entier peut avoir
sur le pays en question et la confiance
est là je crois que la confiance manquer
donc il faudrait rétablir ces éléments
de confiance la deuxième chose crois que
c'est qu'il faut cesser d'arrêter de
séparer la france en deux clans qui
rejettent les fautes sur l'autre camp
car en décapant déculpabilise
incontestablement ce sont des actions
qui sont sur le plan du militantisme pur
sont elles sont bonnes je crois qu'elle
arrange pas nos affaires
il faut que le cnpf et d'un côté le
gouvernement de l'autre cesse de dire
nous on est bien mais les autres sont
pas bien donc je crois qu'il faut une
union nationale au moins dans l'action
pour que l'économie se redresse
troisième c'est le troisième mesure
c'est de ne pas considérer que le marché
des extérieurs s'arrangera en organisant
des deux charters leur charge je vous
fait alésien dame créé son nom tous
l'ont fait c'est traditionnel à chaque
fois qu'on veut gagner les marchés
extérieurs ont rempli à 747
donc je crois que l'exportation c'est
une récompense
c'est lorsqu'on a un produit de très
grande qualité à un prix de revient très
intéressant qu'on commence à attaquer
les marchés étrangers
vous dites souvent tout est permis pour
prendre un créneau sur un marché tout ça
va jusqu'où c'est pas tout est permis
c'est le fait qu'ils aient une nouvelle
règle du jeu du comportement on n'a plus
la chance de pouvoir être à la fois et
mondain et efficace ce qu'était le top
10 en 15 ans pouvait presque par exemple
pour avoir une affaire un marché vous
pratique trier de l'espionnage non c'est
pas pour avoir une affaire une affaire
vous savez maintenant la désinformation
dans la vérité c'est que vous êtes
actuellement dans une guerre économique
très difficile et que malheureusement
vous êtes obligés d'avoir des méthodes
qui sont à la dimension du pari que vous
avez pris quel est le problème
vous avez 1 % de taux de croissance
c'est ce qui vous auto porte et quand
ils affaires ne marchent pas pour la
sortir il faut au moins espérer 20% et
le vrai problème c'est que ces 20% faut
les prendre sur quelqu'un vous êtes donc
contraints d'être dans un système
conflictuelles avec vos concurrents car
c'est sur eux que vous pouvez faire
votre croissance du fret la guerre c'est
la guerre mais c'est vraiment la galère
tous ceux qui veulent pas l'admettre se
trompe c'est une vraie guerre avec tout
ce que ça correspond à l'art au titre de
la guerre bon à partir d'où ces permis
et jusqu'où c'est pas permis un an pour
vous moi je pense que tant que l'équipe
qui est autour de moi que les gens qui
dépendent de moi et que et que les
conséquences de mes actes n'ont pas de
retombées négatives sur la progression
est sur notre avenir je pense que je
peux le faire la morale d'adam n'a rien
à voir il ya de la morale exactement
comme il y en a dans le journalisme
quand on a envie d'arriver et juste au
dessus du copain qui est au dessus du
lot alors pour rester sur la morale
d'ailleurs vous f
bokassa failli vivre chez vous mais
c'est le contraire d'ailleurs comme
histoire seront faits on fait pas mieux
comme vous le dites une histoire sombre
j'ai essayé effectivement de lui prendre
ses châteaux prennent à l'unicef et on
vous avait perdu procès est apparemment
bah oui ça pouvait dire cana qui voulait
que bokassa garde ses chars sont là ça
c'est aussi un côté bernard tapie en
c'est bon on sait plus trop si c'est
sincère si c'est un coup de démagogie de
pub
l'argent à l'unicef vous en avez donné
ses plaies tour c'est peut-être tout en
même temps réel vous en avez donné
finalement laranjeira puisqu'on n'a pas
pu nous laisser les châteaux on est
beaucoup bien d'autres phare de la
région n'a pas attendu l'opération
bokassa pour en donner mais ça c'est pas
le côté qui intéresse les gens
moi je les gens ce qui l'intéresse elle
vaut connaître mieux hu a eu que les
troncs lui mettront du temps à me
connaître quel et quel est l'homme de
l'année pont sur cette année kaba les a
mais les impôts - de très loin et
l'événement de l'année
le véritable événement pour moi c'est
c'est l'installation des piercings et
vous en 84 quel coût vous nous préparez
à meillonnas pas en 84 on en a 5 à faire
d'ici la fin de l'année grain 3-1 à
l'aller 80 cadres vous savez je peux pas
vous dire mais sur 81 3 je crois qu'il y
en a trois dont une très important
laquelle moi c'est impossible de
dévoiler maintenant lui vous allez ça va
dans quelques jours non vraiment je vous
promets que vous allez savoir dans
quelques jours en plus antenne 2 sort en
premier
merci pour nous